To practice filtering queries by property you're going to add
a new function to the conference API class. You can
all the function whatever you like maybe something like Filter
Playground. The name doesn't matter because this function isn't going to
be called by the UI. You'll be using this function
to experiment with filters. You can think of it as a
playground method for exploring queries. This time you can leave
off the @Api Method annotation. You don't have to but it's
a good chance to see what happens if you do.
The method will still be exposed as an endpoint function but
it'll use default values for the publish function name, the path
and the http method. Since we won't be using a form
to post values to this method we don't need to
set the http method to post. It'll work fine to use
the default http method. Define a function to create a query
to get all conferences where the city property has the value
London, sort the query results by conference name. Run
the app on the local host and use the API's
explorer to test it. Look for the new function name
in the list of functions. I called mine filter playground
and you see it shows up here as, conference.conferenceAPI.filterPlayground.
You won't be able to test your new function in
the conference central UI because nothing in the UI calls
your function. I want to emphasize again that you must
run the query first on local host, before you
deploy the App, Appspot and run the query there.
If you deploy it to Appspot first, you'll get
an error when you run the query. Let's execute it
and yes, I have some conferences in London. Obviously, you
need to make sure that you have some conferences in London
or else you won't get any results in this query.
After you got your query to work come back to the
code for your playground method and add another filter. This
time run a filter to check if the topic includes Medical
Innovations. Pay attention the fact that the topics property has a
plural, it's topics. And make sure you spell medical innovations right.
The topics property can have multiple values but you
can create a filter for topics just as you would
for property with a single value. The results will include
applicable conferences, whose topics include
the value, medical innovations. After
you've made the changes to your code run the app
on local host and try out the function in the
API explorer. You'll need to make sure you have some
conferences in London and that the topics include medical innovations.
If you don't get any results check that you
really do have some conferences that meet all those criteria.
Oops, I don't, I'm going to have to go add another
conference. You just wait to create conferences is to use
the create conference page in the UI. So I added
another conference has very good name, chocolate for health and
the topics includes medical innovations, you see that its not
medical innovations is not the only topic, its just one
of the topics and the city is London. So my filters do work. So when you've
got your filters to work go ahead and check the box yes that they're working.